estos son los vectores ahí ve aquí tengo
el vector hay aquí tengo a mi vector p
cuál de los siguientes diagramas
describe una manera válida de obtener a
b y bueno vamos a ver que tenemos por
aquí ok
aquí tengo mi diagrama y si te das
cuenta en este diagrama tengo al mismo
vector am solamente que está trasladado
un poco sin embargo es el mismo vector
am ya este vector a le sumamos el vector
b y llegamos a a más 20 lujo si te das
cuenta este vector a más b empieza en
donde empezó el vector am y termina
justo en el punto en donde termina el
vector d por lo tanto este es mi vector
a más b y esta sí es una representación
correcta de obtener a más de por lo
tanto la voy a poner ahora veamos lo
siguiente dice aquí tengo a mi vector
menos am aquí tengo a mi vector menos b
y aquí tengo a mi vector a más b bueno
pues en definitiva esta no es una opción
correcta aquí en este caso tendríamos
menos a más
más o menos ve lo cual es menos a menos
ve como efectores y no es el vector a
más b por lo tanto esta no es mi opción
correcta y después tengo ambos sin
ninguna pero ya tengo mi respuesta
correcta por lo tanto es momento de
revisar que estemos bien así que vamos a
comprobar respuesta y de lujo estamos
bien